merci beaucoup monsieur le président et
cher
cécilia maelström je pense que c'est un
débat important que nous avons ici ce
soir je vais y revenir dans deux minutes
d'abord je voudrais remercier tous les
rapporteurs fictifs qui se sont tout à
fait impliqué pendant les dernières
semaines ce dossier qui est un dossier
important pas seulement pour la tunisie
mais aussi pour l'europe et polis dès
que nous en avons
vous connaissez tous le contexte
tunisien
vous mesurez tous le chemin qu'a
parcouru ce pays qu'est la tunisie
depuis les dernières révolutions arabes
c'est au fond un des seuls est un des
rares pays qui ait réussi sa transition
démocratique et qui ait réussi à asseoir
cette démocratie
il a d'ailleurs été récompensée à juste
titre par le prix nobel de la paix qui a
été donné pour le dialogue tunisien ceci
était tout à fait justifié mais vous
savez tous ici à quels défis ce pays est
confronté il y a eu bien sûr on s'en
souvient tous les attaques terroristes
qui ont frappé et les terroristes ils
n'ont pas frappé par hazard la tunisie
ils l'ont frappé parce que la tunisie
est en train de réussir et le se faisant
évidemment ils ont mis à mal l'économie
il n'y a plus de tourisme il y à une
crise économique sans précédent il y à
un chômage extrêmement important en
particulier le chômage des jeunes et des
jeunes diplômés
il y à toutes les questions que pose
évidemment le voisinage de la libye et
peut-être demain de l'algérie est donc
oui nous avons besoin que la tunisie
réussisse et oui l'union européenne doit
aider la tunisie à réussir et c'est
l'esprit qui préside aux deux textes que
nous allons nous allons maintenant
parler le premier de ce texte c'est un
texte très important c'est un texte
présenté par la commission ce sont des
mesures d'urgence en faveur de l'huile
d'olive je dis que c'est important je
vais le des clients dans une minute
parce que là il s'agit de faire les
choses concrètement il s'agit pas juste
de parler il s'agit pas de beaux
discours il s'agit d'être au rendez vous
de la solidarité avec la tunisie et avec
les tunisiens ce que la commission
propose c'est tout à fait bien c'est
d'augmenter non pas ce qui est exportée
en huile d'olive de la tunisie mais
d'augmenter de 35 mille tonnes sur deux
années trente cinq mille tonnes par an
sur deux sur deux années les les quotas
d'huile d'olive adroit nul sang exporté
pour autant davantage d'huile d'olive de
la tunisie je vous donne un chiffre nous
produisons en europe plus d'un million
400 mille tonnes d'huile d'olive donc
vous voyez c'est très important pour la
tunisie
ça n'est pas de nature à déstabiliser
l'europe et nous avons obtenu des
amendements d'ailleurs disons que nous
allons revoir au bout d'une année ce
qu'il en sera et que s'il y a un
problème
ce que je ne crois pas mais s'il ya un
problème des mesures seront prises
deuxièmement nous sommes dans un rapport
de la les cas de libre échange avec la
tunisie le premier rand a eu lieu nous
allons voter adopté une résolution
demain sur laquelle nous avons beaucoup
travaillé dans notre commission et le
message du parlement il est simple c'est
pas simplement une résolution qui parle
de commerce et de libre échange c'est
d'abord une résolution politique c'est
une résolution qui dénote solidarité qui
dit note soutien à la démocratie à la
croissance à l'économie et à l'emploi en
tunisie
et cette résolution il donne les
conditions de la réussite nous disons 1
qu'il faut que ce soit politique 2 qu'il
faut que ce soit un accord asymétrique
d'abord pour la tunisie est progressif 3
qu'il y ait de la transparence pas
seulement de la transparence d'ailleurs
mais que les tunisiens dans leur
ensemble s'approprient cet accord qu'ils
en fassent leurs affaires et c'est
pourquoi je suis très heureuse que nous
ayons ce dialogue avec les
parlementaires tunisia que nous avons eu
ici au parlement européen c'est très
important de l'installer de façon
absolument permanente
cet accord il doit servir la tunisie il
doit servir l'ensemble des tunisiens et
à ce moment là nous serons au fond au
rendez-vous de l'exigence qui est la
nôtre être aux côtés de la tunisie et
des tunisiens
je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente merci madame la commissaire
je remercie l'ensemble des intervenants
évidemment de ce débat et je pense que
nous avons tous ici même si à aucun des
sensibilités différentes
un seul objectif c'est que nous voulons
que la tunisie
réussisse et que cette réussite souhaite
aussi pour l'ensemble des tunisiens
deux mots sur l'accord de partenariat je
crois que c'est clair le message d'un
parlement est clair on veut pas
simplement un accord de libre échange ne
veut pas simplement un accord de
commerce on veut entamer un véritable
partenariat politique avec la tunisie
on demande à la commission de faire
preuve d'imagination d'impliquer
vraiment la société civile tunisienne et
je sais que la commission nous entends
et nous entendra sur cette question
c'est très important que les tunisiens
s'approprient ces négociations que ce
soit pas des négociations qui tombe de
nulle part avec entre guillemets des
experts mais que ce soit vraiment la
sphère des tunisiens et des européens
sur la deuxième question
bien sûr qu'il faut aider la tunisie à
court terme c'est pourquoi on a besoin
de ses mesures d'urgence et vous avez
bien fait de rappeler que ce sont les
tunisiens qui les demandent
c'est pas la commission qui s'est
réveillé un jour disant voilà ce qu'on
va faire c'est une demande de la tunisie
c'est très important que l'ensemble de
nos collègues nous entende ce soir il y
a eu des choses divers et variés qui ont
été dites à ce propos mais il ya eu des
choses inexactes qui ont été dites
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation du volume
global des importations d'huile d'olive
de tunisie
aucune augmentation le volume global
restera exactement le même
de plus nous prenons toutes les
précautions
si les amendements que j'ai introduit
que nous avons introduit en commission
seront son voter demain matin ils ont
été en commission nous aurons au bout
d'une année une évaluation précise et
s'il y a des problèmes de déséquilibres
constatés ce que je ne crois absolument
pas à ce moment là la commission
proposera des mesures pour y remédier et
donc vraiment j'appelle l'ensemble des
collègues être au niveau de solidarité
où notre parlement doit être les
tunisiens attendent un signal politique
fort de notre parlement demain soyons à
ce rendez vous merci à tous